at the foot of the tianshan mountains
kyrgyz farmers guide their horses
towards fields
where the snow is less deep so they can
graze
horses from this region were fought over
and prized by nomad clans invading
armies
and russian settlers for centuries
to farmers like bucket chokyov they are
a source of wealth cultural identity
and national
the pride is the kirkey's man's right
hand we are originally normal
we discovered new places riding horses
like this we drink their milk and eat
their meat
horses mean so much for our culture
each of these animals is worth around
two thousand dollars protecting them
from mountain predators can be a
challenge
especially at this time of year
this winter has been very bad for
attacks by wolves
four horses in the village have been
killed so far
for the farmer the hardy indigenous
breeds of horses remain fundamental to
their working lives but they also breed
them
with animals from europe and one of the
reasons is a desire for victory
in the national sport the game of ulak
tartish demands a horse not only be
strong
riders wrestle over a goat carcass they
have to drop the animal into a score
zone to win
points kinan sadira kulov has been
competing for four years
his horse polkovnik meaning colonel in
english
is a kyrgyz european mixed breed
we need them to be agile and fast
there's a lot of horses with physical
ability but they get scared
they also can't be too tall because we
need to bend them down and grab the good
carcass
russian settlers were the first to mix
kyrgyz with european breeds when they
came to this region in the mid 19th
century
there is now increasing interest among
stud farm owners like
bechter shabnakov to breed pure european
horses specifically for racing
he breeds imported english animals which
cost from around fifty thousand dollars
to transport from the uk
the difficulties of raising pure foreign
breeds is you need better quality
pasture and vitamins
they're not used to harsh winters it's
much more challenging and expensive
horses are a way of life in this
mountainous region of central asia
for bucket and his fellow herders they
mean more
than money and prestige
al jazeera northern kyrgyzstan